on n'a pas
m
[Musique]
il
paris
michel olive tout ça
la voix du sud
1 on pas terrestre j'ai un
extraterrestre tu veux savoir ce qui
m'intéresse mais bien mixer pas de fer
le bois il ou en terrasse c'est un
problème bien bon et qu'on habite pas
loin
tu te sens tu m'aimes pas moi je ne
pensais pas moins que rien
pour lui la seconde petit coup de gueule
vous avez du temps les halles ou encore
prostituées et ce plaisir aussi coûté
pour choquer et charles aznavour
emmenez moi c'est un classique
m
moi ça fait partie du jeu est ce que
c'est un mec qui évolue bien sûr c'est
le mec qui tape le plus bien sûr c'est
un gars john quand il sort un album déjà
c'est un événement et en plus de ça à la
fin de la semaine tu encore notre album
à la fin de la semaine tu dis bon
bah j'ai écouté l'album de jul demain ça
ira
et en même temps tu as demain ça ira 2
par exemple hier tranquillou voilà ça va
faire mal on va casser des nues
ce qui est très bon rappeur évidemment
qui sont passés dans planète rap il est
très bon des pubs
voilà beaucoup de beaucoup de
personnalité mais des vrais vrai talent
et qui dure surtout c'est très rare
quand même il ya une chose est sûre le
conduit aujourd'hui à l'épreuve et
demain ça ira
aujourd'hui tient pas de conduite de
média packagé demain ça ira vendre mais
ça ira c'est comme j'ai dit c'est un
message d'espoir c'est c'est pour tous
c'est pour tout le monde c'est demain ça
ira ira plus qu vide
on sera plus confiné j'espère que l'on
retombe rappelé une merde du ciel si
pour le retour parce que au nom mais
vous êtes la preuve avec les retours que
j'ai bien travaillé
alors comme ça tu passes à côté de moi
tu me filme pas mal à terminer je savais
yves lutte
on est des amis on se connaît tous très
long time maintenant donc c'est là
qu'ils font guère
[Applaudissements]
bien peu plus tard c'est comme ça c'est
la cité
m
énergie
[Musique]
non
autrement dit kenny ce duo offensif
d'accord
alors je sais pas
c'est là que tu dois garder ils sont
interdits
moi je
gros là il veut brut et
et séance dédicace et tranquille 12
aujourd'hui on a filmé de faire deux
titres en live de son nouvel album à
marseille voilà dans une salle avec du
public pour brut sur un concept qu'on a
écrit avec un bras robot et un écran de
l'aide qui se répondent
[Musique]
donc là je bouge pas ouais là l'idée
vrai après tout qu'un peu d'attitude
nasa de toi donc on s'est calmé
[Musique]
joli on n'est pas bon merci beaucoup
et merci brut 1 c'est la zone merci à
tous a dit toi
ça
dis toi
tous être en mesure c'est un exemple un
exemple un grand homme dans
grand calme en 2010 selon m vivendi kg
mais on est les dernières passes et bons
billets on espère passer un peu de temps
[Musique]
la ctb avec tout l'équipage à l' onu
poster vos forces à la team gaulle
toujours à lever ces machines
[Musique]